remember after the photo shoot I was in
the limo going back to training
facilities with coach Ditka and he
looked at me and he says I don't know
how they got you to put on a wedding and
again I was like you're supposed to tell
me this before
[Music]
Rickey how you doing man can't you play
when you first start playing pool kind
of a rite of passage is when you get
that big paycheck you get your own house
kind of put a pool table in the house so
when I got to New Orleans I had a full
table in the house let's see what you
can do
Rickey there was a lot of controversy
your rookie year a lot was going on I
want to hear from your perspective I've
been dying to ask this question yeah
what was your roofie year like in the
world no there was an article at the end
of my rookie year in the SP of the
magazine and it was titled the season
from hell and that's that was my year it
all started with of all things my choice
of agent I want to find someone that I
could connect with and at the time
Master P said yes he I started No Limit
sports and I can't really close with
with one of his runners I just felt like
family
you know and no limit was that was on
top at that moment you know just
dreaming about having a change no limit
to exactly so it started off with that I
got a lot of flack for signing signing
with No Limit scores took them with me
to the combine what a nightmare
my only half an hour doing the combine I
walk in the room and there's a room full
of guys and I'm in my underwear first
they measure my hands right and then
they measure the width of your hands 1/8
1/4 it's got to get it down to the seat
of civic inch exactly and then you know
after that they realized I had the
smallest hands in the draft and then was
it doozy you know they yell out your
weight ok and so sitting on I was dead
on the scale the guy says to
42.8 you can hear a gasp like your
collective gasp in the
and then of course the next day articles
about small hands over weight and size
issues like exactly the journey he
started started then another funny story
so you know before the draft I went to
visit the teams that was we're looking
at drafted me and I went to New Orleans
and we went to we went to lunch at a
famous Italian restaurant in New Orleans
and you know how at the end of a meal
they bring out the dessert tray and they
say you know pick what you want so they
bought the dessert tray and I like
desserts you know and then my mind I was
thinking a lot of these desserts looked
good you know but I just chose one if I
chose one and they came back around and
said you want another dessert and I was
thinking well if they're asking me you
know that means I'm supposed to say yeah
yeah and it came back again instead you
were another dessert three rounds the
desserts three rounds the desserts and I
figured you know Mike Vick is here the
you know the vice president's here they
seem like they're okay and so I said
sure I'll have another dessert not
realized and I came into the meeting
with the weight problem and they here
here right in front of them in front of
that no shame you know I had three
desserts but you know the year the year
just kept on going and it didn't get
much better so I finally make it into
training camp and when I got off the
plane there was a bunch of reporters and
they had a magazine in their hand
you know and earlier earlier that summer
I did a photo shoot with coach Ditka
frías for the magazine and at the time
the writer for you at ESPN the magazine
dan-levitan one of my best friends at
the time we were talking about you know
how do we want to do this this photo
shoot to you know to to commemorate the
Saints drafted me with training all the
pigs and so he said you know it's kind
of like a marriage and so what if we did
a picture of you in a wedding dress in
coach Ditka and the tuxedo and at the
time I was in the car and I and I laugh
and I said that would be really funny
and I
think about it until I decided to do the
photo shoot remember after the photo
shoot I was in the limo going back to
the training facility with coach Ditka
and he looked at me and he says I don't
know how they got you to put on a
wedding ago and again I was like you're
supposed to tell me this before the
photo shoot to me I just thought it was
like Halloween wearing a costume but it
got blown out of proportion and first
day at training camp I had to deal with
this controversy and they really set up
a theme for my whole rookie season
there's just all this controvert really
my whole time in New Orleans dealing
with off-the-field controversy that
detracted me from what I had to do all
my feel as you look back on that
scrutiny the the talk how'd you handle
all that another rookie mistake not very
well no I remember one day training camp
it was raining so I had my helmet on go
into a covered area to do an interview I
got to the to the picnic bench and I sat
down on the bench and as soon as I hit
the bench one of the media yeah take off
your helmet and I and it hit me in that
moment like what if I don't want to know
until I said mild and I said what if I
don't want to and then I just did the
interview with my helmet on just at one
time and as I was doing the interview I
felt
empowering you know there I was
struggling with this relationship with
the media where they feel they can just
take take take and I felt like I had
nothing to myself and I felt like that
that gesture of rebellion help me stay
sane and not feel like I was giving up
too much and so it became a kind of
routine that throughout the whole season
after practice I'd always wear a helmet
do my during my interviews and that
became another thing that that added to
the Ricky weirdo story and kind of
separated me from from my teammates to
shut
did you feel more pressure as a result
in no I'm I'm asked that question a lot
in if I'm being honest I didn't I didn't
feel the pressure I think part of it is
I put so much pressure on myself to be
great a good example of that is my
rookie contract which was another part
of the season the way I looked at it I
thought you know I'll get a signing
bonus and this is my reward for what I
did in college but everything I do at
this level I should have to earn it and
so I told my I told my agent I want to
make the minimum base salary and in
order for me to make a lot of money I
need to have to perform looking back on
that do you regret that I do I did you
know and there's and I'll tell you why
there's a theme that runs through my
whole rookie year and there's a term in
football rookie mistakes I made a lot of
rookie mistakes you know I was just
young and naive and idealistic you know
and the one thing that I didn't take
into consideration is what if I get hurt
you know and again I hadn't had the
experience up until that point of
missing any game so it didn't even cross
my mind do you think you can be
idealistic and play football I think if
you're an idealist you're gonna be
disappointed a lot but if you do enough
you open doors so that your ideals can
come to fruition later and that's what
I'm starting to see now things that I
believed in I'm starting to see them
implemented more now into the NFL I like
to think that you know my brief stint in
the NFL contributed to things moving
forward and in exchange I think the
biggest one would be marijuana
yeah conversation around marijuana how
as you look back on that as disruptive
is he worth at the time speaking out
openly about it how do you look about
the current NFL situation how marijuana
is treated and looked at it's crazy I
mean it's the NFL it sports in general
but it's really our whole society in you
know I was shamed so much for this you
know 15 years ago and now I get calls
from ESPN to come on television and talk
about it you know so again it's it's
things have moved in and I feel like
I've done my part to be to be a part of
the change and that feels good
but it was rough you know and I think
anyone you know who's been a trailblazer
will have scars to do
to prove it they got that possible
anything's possible
okay there it is thanks for kicking it
with us subscribe to be our to check out
more dope videos like this one